اليوم اذا يعيد الى الاذان اثمار بني في
العمليات اقتحام السابقه قادها السياسي
الاسرائيلي المتطرف رفقه مستوطنين
يتشاركون معه الافكار نفسها فيما يلي اذن
عرض لابرز اقتحامات باحات الاقصى التي
قادها اجمار بنكسير تصاعد التوتر في القدس
الشرقيه المحتله في التاسع والعشرين من
مايو 2021 عقب دخول مئات الاسرائيليين
ساحات المسجد الاقصى قبيل الساعات من
مسيره الاعلام ونجحت مجموعه منهم في
الدخول بقيادته في العاشر من يونيو 2021
فشلت عمليه اقتحام للمسجد الاقصى بعد
التصدي المقدسيين للمستوطنين وفي مقدمتهم
عضو الكنيسه انا ذاك اثمار
مره اخرى في السابع والعشرين من يونيو
2021 واقتحم المسجد الاقصى رفقه مستوطنين
من باب المغاربه وتحت حمايه شرطه الاحتلال
عمليه اقتح الاخرى على بني كثير سجلت في
الحادي والثلاثين من مارس 2022 بعد موافقه
الشرطه الاسرائيليه على طلبه كرر بريك في
الاقتحام الاقصى في الثالث والعشرين من
سبتمبر 2022 في منطقه باب المغاربه بحراسه
الشرطه الاسرائيليه في السادس من نوفمبر
2022 اددى بن كثير ومجموعه من المستوطنين
المتطرفين طقوسا دينيه في المنطقه الشرقيه
من الاقساط
وحاول بني كثير بالوصل تحريضه على اقتحام
الاقصى فظهر في تسجيل في الحادي عشر من
ديسمبر الماضي وهو يحث وانصاره على اقتحام
المسجد بالتزامن مع الاعياد اليهوديه